councillors it's
just gone three o'clock
so reminder that we've just started the
stream and if you've got a cell phone on
vibrate not to leave it on the table
welcome along i'll declare this meeting
of the performance policy
and partnerships committee open there
are no
apologies as always any changes to the
uh interest register can be made with
malavika at any stage
so that brings us on to the minutes of
the community
wellbeing fund committee councillor
lewis
i'd like to move those to you accepted
thank you
moved is there a seconder for that all
right
counselor partner anything you'd like to
draw our attention to counsellor
no just one small item in public
republicans do you want to pull that
microphone and please sorry
thanks there's one small aspect in
public
excluded but nothing really in this that
was other than it was a successful
funding round
and uh well attended by members of the
community who are also on on the
on the chair on the board or
the committee i should say and my
particular thanks to the staff who
arranged
a lot of the interviews even sometimes
trying to
put some of the public straight on the
aspects of the funding
being a new committee it was done most
professionally and but lots of hours
done by by the
staff and i thank them for that thank
you thanks councillor it's been moved
and seconded
put the motion all in favor all right
all right against
carried we've got the minutes of our
meeting
on april 13th which i'm happy to move is
there a second
second though any matters arising
there are none i've got the motion all
in favor
against carried grunt
coming up to the big red chair
welcome along grant uh fisher who's
got the paper that you'll of course read
on the national policy statement
on urban development and the removal of
minimum car parking rates from
from our district plan um just as an
overview before i hand over to grant uh
it's a national policy statement so
it's it's one of those things that we
just really are
obliged to to enact but don't grant you
want to take us through the paper please
yeah good uh kia ora everyone um so
the report relates to national direction
that we've been given
to remove on-site parking requirements
from our district plan
the policy relating to this
was passed in august 2020 so it's august
last year
we've been through the
district plan and identified all of the
policies and rules etc which do require
amendment
and that's in appendix 2 of this report
the recommendations to receive the
report
and to approve the preferred option
which is to remove
all policies rules assessment criteria
etc which relate to
provision of on-site parking from
airplane thanks grant from memory
there was already an exemption within
the cbd area
but this is just pushing out much wider
that's correct
thanks for that explanation um we've got
two recommendations do we have a mover
i'll move that way mr chair on the basis
that it is both
sensible and legislatively compliant to
do so
thank you secondary secretary thank you
councillor abbott it's open for
questions or comments councillor
pottinger
i guess it's regarding the the wider
policy statement on urban development
and just interested in the
classifications of tier one and tier two
and
we invercargill falls outside both of
those
and obviously the policy statement comes
in with
um advice for tier one and tier two
new regulations is that right that's
correct yeah um
so really the only one that hits us is
there is that
car parking one uh there's carpet three
uh tier three yeah um they're all
uh it's also encouraged though that tier
three authorities
um take on board the other policies
which relate to the larger
councils um uh particularly around urban
land supply
right the urban that's the one i wanted
to get to and obviously the urban land
supply
they're actually asking us through this
statement to be
proactive is that right um
somewhat and um also to um
monitor um key housing indicators as
well so
you know affordability is obviously one
of those yeah gotcha so if we
rather than being reactive when there's
nothing left we should be
monitoring it see how this is filling up
yeah
we need to be one step ahead 100 yeah
thanks thank you
thanks for that any other questions or
comments
if not it's been moved in second and
i'll put the motion all in favor
aye against carried
and uh staying with you we now come to
the poor wide development
uh a request for a private plan change
yeah that's correct um that probably
dovetails quite nicely into council um
is it possible
that's me yeah sure that's right here
yeah it's gonna see you uh
in front of the just hiding there um
um so the background to
this report is councils received the
request for a private plan change to
a large site on the corner of rockdale
road
in tramway road so that's the south
eastern end of invercargill
it's presently zoned rural um although
it is identified in our district plan as
an uh outlying development plan area
so um it's already signaled in our
district plan
that um this is where we want urban
development to occur in the future
subject to a plan change application
which is what we've got in front of us
today
the general proposal is for
most of the site to be rezoned as
residential one which is our standard
residential
zone throughout the city but it also
have a
core commercial small commercial
development area
surrounded by a medium residential
density zone
um the proposal also indicates a range
of
reserves for stormwater management uh
recreation
and sets out principal layout around
roading etc as well
um the
recommendations in front of you
[Music]
the preferred recommendation is to adopt
the plan change
which is as if the council takes over
the proposal
and manages it as if it's a
council-initiated proposal from here on
out
and really the the key reasons for that
as outlined on in my report
um really that
the site is already identified within a
district plan
as being the next area for urban
development
um and also hits those um uh
high level uh aspirations if that's
right the right word
for um for urban land supply as well so
that's
um counselor punjab that's sort of
responding to that um
proactive approach to urban land supply
right
there's also an alternative option there
um
which is the the next rank down in our
in our preference which is to accept the
plan change request
um and the key difference there is it
becomes
still it still is retained as a
private plan change so uh
we wouldn't necessarily need to well
council
makes decisions on that plan change as
if it's a private
claim change request um
yeah i'm happy to take any questions if
that's clear enough thanks
grant so as grant outlined it really is
the
a good case scenario as far as council's
concerned it's an area that had been
identified
when we reviewed the district plan it is
a development where the developer came
in and started
working with council from from the
outset to ensure that
they would be able to find the easiest
pathway to to achieve what it was that
that they were looking for so we've got
a recommendation
to receive the report and adopt option
one which is to adopt the proposed plan
change
someone prepared to move counselor
arnold what are you wanting to speak
a question okay well can i get a motion
on the table first move counselor scout
seconded uh councillor sopa allen
i was just going to ask um is this the
preferred option of the actual developer
himself
uh yes
so the um the application as you see it
in front of you
um and this is appendix one
is the development proposal which was
submitted to
us um and then it's been slightly
modified
by way of uh a further information
request and that request is
a response to that request has come in
responding to our um
so they're very happy with that um i
believe so yeah cool
any further questions or comments
so the three recommendations move
counselor scout seconded counselor sopa
i'll put that then
all in favor aye against
carried
thank you thank you do a quick seat
change
and that brings us on to the um
building consent authority strategic
review jonathan
cura got it welcome along
do you want to give us an overview of
the review
uh so um essentially as part of our uh
planning
each year we do quarterly strategic
reviews with the um ceo
for icc uh the most recent strategic
review which i think was held
last month we discussed the improved
performance of the icc building team
over probably the course of the last
year
to the point that we have actually
achieved 100 compliance with the
statutory clocks
for both issuing building consensus and
code compliance certificates
thanks jonathan um and i think it's
worth reiterating the point that you
know
but over 12 months ago we were sitting
here subject to some
uncomfortable presentations from people
within the community
um the department managed to to
to turn that around through service
delivery and now to get
um the sign off uh as a credit so
thank you for the work that's that's
been put in i'm happy to move the two
recommendations
there a second a second it's open for
question or comment
counselor edmondson then councillor sofa
thanks it's not
a question really just want to reiterate
what the chair has said
about the incredible change that's
happened
in this department over the last 12
months um
i'm really impressed with how quickly
it's been able to be turned around and
the positive feedback that i've
certainly been getting from
out in the community about the building
consent department now so
thank you very much
thanks mr chair pretty much the same i
just don't think it should go without
without some good comment from
councillors that say
congratulations to the department on uh
turnaround that's been really quite
spectacular
and that pays a lot of tribute to the
sort of work that our very professional
staff have put in
to a big job
thank you you've seen a high bar
good luck in maintaining it i'm sure you
will it's been moved and seconded i'll
put the motion all in favor
against carrie
and darren i'd like to recognize the
role you've played in that as well for
those of you who might not be aware this
is
uh mr edwards last meeting with us he
finishes with council at the end of this
week
now before we move on to the next meaty
item i just want to take the opportunity
to say that during a short time
you have sean brightly and and played a
significant role
in in helping to improve our customer
focus
and and how people engage with council
and and we thank you sincerely for that
and and wish you all the best in your
return home
mr morris
you may approach the bench
good afternoon cheer your worship
counsellors um
his counselor ludlow has described it as
a meaty topic
uh that has been vexing numerous
councils throughout the country
uh it is the decision on whether we
establish
whether you establish a maori ward today
you will note that that's not the
recommended outcome
but first by a bit of background as i'm
sure you're all aware the government
changed the law recently enabling
councils to reconsider or consider
refresh or consider for the first time
establishing a maori ward in time for
next year's
triangle council elections the date to
make that decision is by the 21st of may
so today's the day essentially
uh as part of that we bought a report
through to council
in march and we're given a direction to
go and consult with the community
we have now done that and we dovetailed
a lot of that and with the long-term
plan consultation so that we were
trying to capture as many people as we
possibly could so i
do need to acknowledge rhiannon and her
team for the assistance they
gave to make sure that that could happen
uh and then
secondly also uh councillor munson and
the community panel
uh for their role in engaging with the
with the public so uh david anna
uh adi and michael skerritt then
seconded by evelyn cook so they've done
an excellent job
gathering the information that is now
contained in the report
and of that consultation i probably wish
to highlight only our um
meeting at the mirahuku morai it was a
very clear message from
ewe that day that they did not wish to
see a maori ward created but
wanted to see progress on manifeno
assets
gathering the feedback the feedback was
quite clear that the majority of people
strongly support
a greater maori voice on council it was
simply the mechanisms to make that
happen
and the recommendation is therefore that
we do not establish
a maori award but that we
start the process of creating manafenoua
seats
on council committees and
on full council noting that the full
council role would be advisory only does
not have
voting rights and that was endorsed by
the community panel from
their feedback so i am more than happy
to answer any questions
thanks michael um first from me
the secondary recommendation is
requesting a report to be prepared on on
the monofinal receipt so
that's the beginning of of that process
is the
additional consultation you envisages is
needed
to prepare that report yes so it would
be to discuss with manafenoua to
understand what exactly their
aspirations for those seats would be
there would be additional consultation
on that specific topic
i expect with our community as we go
through that reporting process
but it would also be an opportunity to
set out actually the framework for how
these seats work and we'll give the
opportunity to look at what documents we
would need to change to make that
a reality and it would hopefully set a
time frame
if it was to proceed uh with when that
would be whether they would be brought
in before the 2022 elections whether
that would be the
start those sort of conversations still
need to be had which is what that report
would proceed with thanks along with his
his worship um i joined with staff in
going to the
marae consultation and it was very
interesting
and a very clear message uh that we were
given i was wondering how
the the subject of of maori wards was
going to go when we went to ewe uh i
mean we've all received email
from members of the public that
presents a viewpoint of resistance and
and
we've seen some of those um issues
across the country in in recent years
but the concerns of of aiwee were about
the the monophenol status and in the way
um maori wards can be catered for in the
current legislation
and they were not comfortable with it so
but they were obviously interested
in engaging further with council
and wondering where we stood with the uh
the manufino receipts on on council
committees
i appreciate that it's slightly
different with our committee structure
but there was no doubt that there was a
clear message on that day
councillor amundsen what was the the
feedback that that you received through
the representation review
thanks councillor ludlow um yeah uh the
feedback that the community panel came
back with is
as reflected in the report um really
clear message
that council needed to do a better job
of
engaging with maori and
you know having a genuine partnership
with maori you know under our treaty
obligations
when we talk to people about what a
maori ward would look
like and what manafinoa seats would look
like it was really clear that people
thought that manafenoua seats
actually had more value partly because
it's more representative of ewi from the
community um
ahmadi ward of course meant that anybody
could stand in that seat
and it also meant unless we were going
to create a
complicated award system for
invercargill
that actually people on the maori roll
would actually only get one vote for one
person on council
whereas everybody else would get to vote
for the other 11 people on council
and there seemed like a real concern
that that didn't really seem that fair
so certainly the panel endorsed the
recommendation
that is in here to
request a report about malafinoa seats
and agrees with the approach
that has been suggested around setting
out an approach to
how we would develop those seats and
what those seats would look like
and having a panel to oversee that
process and i guess i'd
just like to also add that the role that
maori play
in developing what that looks like is
going to be the most integral part of
that process
so i'm more than happy to remove the
recommendations i'm happy to second them
was there much discussion uh around
ensuring a voice for matawaka
so that was discussed and certainly
uh the process for them could be
to go through ewe to you know take
any concerns or issues that they had you
know once these were established
through ewe but also included the
conversation about
how can we as a council better engage
with all groups in our community
including matawaka to make sure that
when we are doing things where we are
engaging with our community
um that we are making sure we
we're checking in with all the different
community groups including matawaka
i guess one of the points it's worth
following up on is this is your
second time engaged in the
representation review and
in the previous time we were already
told that there was insufficient
engagement with uh with maori and
now is the time a few years later that
we really need to
step up our game yeah and that was
really clear in 2015 when we did the
representation review
um at that time the question about
ahmadi ward was actually just dealt with
by
um council staff and councillors going
to
um you know going to the marae
and having a conversation and that was
kind of the end of it
it didn't include any wider engagement
with the wider community
councilor soper then councillor abbott
thank you mr chia i just wanted to
follow up your comment about mata waka
and say i'm
very much in favor of these
recommendations i see it as a
a major step forward for this council
and as i have said earlier the time has
come
for us to consider this whole issue in
in new ways on the particular matter of
mata waka i'm very
keen that as part of producing a new
report
as we're requesting here that there
is a meeting perhaps held on naha
afar and toimarangi mirai
um the two mata wakamurais as well as
murohu which has had
a meeting till now and at araha
i think that's exceptionally important
for us to be seen to be
seriously seriously
making that doing that relationship
building with
naitahu and matawaka in this case
we want as a council to absolutely get
this
right and i think that that will be
quite a contribution to showing how
serious we are
about furthering this conversation
thank you councillor abbott uh really
just a point of clarification i think
that i want i understand that the report
will be forthcoming
but in the texts it calls
about two seats or these seats
and i just want the question um is there
any one representative for the two
committees
or is it two representatives one for
each committee
mr morris so that would be determined
um because we have to rinanga in the
city
uh so it is possible in theory to have
a representative from both through nanga
uh
it's more likely to be one
representative per
committee but that could be the same
person or a different person
those things would be determined as we
work with uh ewe
on that development of those seats right
i thought that would be forthcoming in
the report but i just wanted to clarify
it at this stage
so it is potentially one on each yes
okay councillor pottinger then
councillor lash
thank you cheer um so i take it there is
no model
for what we are going to be uh looking
into
that's right in new zealand so a number
of other councillors do have
manifenoa seats currently so um
wellington city for example
has established them and i am aware
there are a number
environment south and hereford so is
there anything that
local government in nz would want to
help with
or is that something because obviously
this is
pretty it's pretty inspirational
exploratory stuff
and it's customized obviously to each
each area
yeah so i understand our local
government new zealand do have some
guidance available uh and that would be
part of our
forthcoming report right excellent
councilor lash it could just i spoke to
um
council soap earlier about this but
could you just explain to me just for a
point of clarification
the basis of this
with its uh relationship between council
and just the manufacturing and not the
manawaka how
what where that actually goes back
can you explain to me
it's hard for me to ask the question
where it's legislated that we have to
deal with the
man of whenua um is that from the
principles of the treaty is that where
that
that comes from it's essentially yes
because they hold
so ewe nato hold manifeno a status here
so they are the custodians of
this land so which is why we have to
um work with them because they have that
right
uh so the local government act
specifically generally talks about maori
it doesn't distinguish between matawaka
and manafenoa
other pieces of legislation like the
resource management act for example
specifically talks about manafenoua
so when we are working on matters such
as this
it is with manafenuwa who hold that
status as the custodians and guardians
of this land
that we work with under the treaty mata
waka need to be considered as part of
that wider picture of almighty to make
sure
that if we are having manufenua seats
that we don't
essentially disenfranchise mata waka
from feeling that they have
a voice in the city but manafenou are
the people who have the right to speak
for
the land people so you're confident we
followed this process through
in the consultation that would that
we've yes done it the right way i guess
thank you
to me thank you for uh councillor clark
sure um i've already declared
to my colleagues that i'm opposed to the
second recommendation
and i've got a list of reasons why so
i'm just going to run through those
naitah has already declared in this
process that they're not interested in
the maori ward
and i understand the logic for that
although i do
it does concern me that um mary
does not mean manofenua it means
so award covers all those that are on
the tea titanium electorate
and so we get confused when we talk
about maori awards versus
um monophenolic seeds so these i think
that's what you were leading to marcus
the second issue for me is naitaahu has
recently declined to have
four roonanga seats represented on the
southland mayoral forum
and i find that quite disappointing
given that that's a significant
governance board
in southland that covers all the um
uh four councils and they declined to
often have representation there
yesterday for some who know that i was
in christchurch with a meeting with
naitahu over three waters
it was reiterated by naito that they
have rangatiratanga which is
self-determination
across the direction on which they're
going and i thought that was really
interesting to discuss that
because they said that they are the only
tribal settlement that has that written
into their act so the 1998
naitah settlement act has rangatiratanga
incorporated within it where all the
other settlements do not
that gives them some uniqueness within
our within our region
um but they are quite clear that they
want to be
in a separate national government
structure
um and so i thought that was really
interesting um given that we
are currently under review by the palmer
led government group
around local government i think it's too
early to be deciding on
whether we have seats or don't have
monofinalist seats
we don't know what the shape of our
local environment will be in southland
we may end up with just a unitary
authority
and so i think we're jumping ahead a
little bit
and when it refers to all our current
committees well we actually have
three committees because we have the
risk and assurance as well
and so we may have three representatives
and we have full council so potentially
we have
potentially four four groups to have
a monophenol representation on and i
think that creates
a whole lot of issues as well um because
uh when we deal with
some issues at the mayoral forum level
we have some difference between
aurora and wahoopa already and so that
gives us a lack of uniformity
and i think and finally i think that the
the seats
um being designated for monophenol would
go too far at this stage
i think because the thrust of the
representation review that we've done
was around maori wards which is a much
wider picture
so given it in southam we've probably
got um
sixty percent of our every population is
not manifest
i think it disengages them some to be
suggesting that they can
have their rights represented through a
naitahu sort of subgroup
and so based on all those things i'm
opposed to
the recommendation too i just think we
should leave it until we're
clearer about where to from here and the
other thing for us i guess is that
the current all of council committees
that we drive through at the moment are
a little bit unique in new zealand
there's i think about 20
of councils have got these all of
council committees
but our one doesn't survive beyond the
next election and i think we've got
we've already discussed that we've got a
review in place and it could be that
after the next election
we go back to what we had before which
was a full council
making all the binding decisions and the
committee's making recommendations
and if that's the case then the
representation on both those two would
be different so you could have somebody
sitting on a uh from monofin or sitting
on a committee making a recommendation
but when it got to full council they may
or may not have voting rights and i
think it's
we've jumped way ahead of ourselves in
this discussion we should just
leave it alone at that we don't want to
marry water the stage and come back to
the
issue of representation on committees
once we know what our committees will be
in the future
councillor pottinger um just
understanding
uh recommendation two we we obviously
it's quite clear the first part we're
not establishing murray ward
but getting a report is not a binding
it's a report
and opens the door for discussion and
options
with the guidance of you know as lgnc
and other people so i can't quite
understand why we wouldn't do that
report even though there are other
things happening in the world god
there's asteroids flying everywhere you
know we don't stop for those
never mind the asteroids as chinese
spaceships uh
councillor cricket then councillor
amundsen oh thank you council ludlow um
uh my statement is kind of along this
similar lines to council of hodinger
because we we do know that we have about
30 plus pieces of legislation that we're
accountable to
and within that we've got an obligation
to uphold te taliti
and enable and that's a key word enable
maori participation on council at the
governance level
and currently i don't see us doing that
the simple fact is our status quo is
just not enough
we have a partnership obligation
partnership being key
throughout the founding of this country
and it's enforced by legislation that
we're clearly not upholding
it's my belief that today is the day to
change that and that we need to be
taking
steps forward that will shape our city
and move us ahead
with this there's literally nothing to
lose
and everything to gain a decision to at
least not investigate it like councillor
pottinger has stated
to investigate it to get the report is a
complete rejection
on increased participation partnership
is equal
relationships need to be given the money
that they deserve
status quo acknowledges neither of these
nor does it
acknowledge our legislative requirements
participation is the first step
on the path to us fulfilling those
obligations
we must simply seek the report
we must consult with maori for a maori
outcome
decided by maori that actual those
engaging in those conversations and
talking to them
about what they see the future and
participation to be is absolutely
integral
we can't make that decision for maori
maori must make that decision for
themselves
and everything that i do with council i
um
we actually have a phrase that is coined
making makapuna decisions throughout a
national committee that i'm involved
with the young elected members
committee and it's you know we're making
decisions for the for not for ourselves
but for our future
generations and that's something that i
absolutely feel applies to this
particular
decision and one the this maori wards
thing it's
something that just it's on the tip of
people's tongues it's something you hear
about and
throughout the ltp consultation is one
of the things that we've been speaking
about the most
and i had um a young maori person say to
me
how would you feel if you were only
bought out for
a puffity and that really really
drove home to me why
increased participation is just so
integral for this council
thank you councillor evanson with your
forgiveness i'll hold off on you as the
mover of the motion to be the final
speaker council of sopa
oh thank you i thought there was someone
before me
there was counselor and then his worship
thank you mr chair um
i suppose i want to start off if you
will allow me by paraphrasing
what napera said in 1840
the shadow stays with with this the
shadow goes to the crown
the substance stays with us now i'm not
going to go
through the long history of the treaty
since that point
and the arguments about the
interpretations of kawangatanga and tino
rangatiratanga
but i am going to say that there was a
treaty signed a unique treaty to new
zealand a covenant
between two peoples lord cook in 1987
talked about
that being showing a relationship
established that was a
of a fiduciary nature akin to a
partnership
we have a definition in much of our
legislation of the principles of the
treaty
that includes governorship
self-management
equality reasonable cooperation redress
as councillor crackett has said we have
a long history that we can quote from
of principles that we must uphold
for me this calling for a report today
is part of saying to the murray of this
invercargill city and the wider province
that we are prepared to talk about the
substance
that we are long past the shadow in 2021
and that we are a council who will start
the talk about
a relationship a partnership the
building
of a proper relationship that allows for
a voice to be heard
that we are prepared to take a substance
decision now this is calling for a
report
there will be decisions to make once we
have that very comprehensive report
but for me it is a major set for this
council many other councils in new
zealand have already taken it
many other councils already have
something in place
around manafenoua seats for this council
i urge us to be brave and to say
the time has come when we had
the substance conversation 1840
we signed a covenant a partnership
agreement
it is time for this council to say we
are prepared to go to the next step
of turning that into a reality
thank you your worship yes
i find myself in a difficult situation
because i'm
voting in support of my colleague
chancellor sober for the first time
and it is a difficult
situation but i think we can't
just say oh we've got a report we've
taken a step forward
and leave it at that it has enormous
meaning when you
when you work in cooperation with
another organisation
and we fail it's not just us but
um other councils uh it's been suggested
um have faced this problem i faced it
early on
when we as mayor of waidamata city where
we had um to
we found the biggest obstacle to maori
development
in the appalling statistics shown in the
health admissions and prison admissions
and
all the rest that the biggest obstacle
was council bureaucracy
and so we invented a new zone called the
mirai zone
and on the mariah zone you got do
carving you could do education you could
do athletics
it didn't matter what path they chose to
go down
they would have the support of council
and that this is just the beginning i
mean if you think
the report's going to end controversy
i see the seabed and foreshore as
cropped up again
i was uh proudly arrested
for being on the maori land march and
trying to change
the the economic development of the
tangata pinua
uh with a bastion point
occupation that lasted nine months
and there were 222 arrests
but again that was a statement by this
council saying yes we're going to
support
the future aspirations
of the maori people and
i believe it's important that history
records that
thank you worship councillor kent yeah
thank you chairman
um over the years i've even before i was
elected on the council
i believe we've always had a fair
representative representation of mary
at times we had a third of our members
at the moment i believe we've got three
and i've
always been of the belief that you know
if you're going to have say around a
council table
um i believe you should be elected there
the voting systems that we have in place
are very fair
very fair indeed and no one is at a
disadvantage
so i would like to stick with the status
quo i believe everyone should stand on
their
own two feet and go to the polling booth
thank you councillor um councillor lewis
thank you chair it still comes down to
the actual words in this in this
recommendation
request a report be prepared in a minor
final receipts on council committees and
full
council we seem to be slightly going off
the track and various things it is
asking for a report
one of the committees in fact two of the
committees i have in the chair
we have maori representation i'm not too
sure of the mona fenola
or matawaka what they are but the the
input
on that committee from all the members
on the committee are very important but
i'm very privileged to have that extra
expertise from the maori representation
on some funding issues um i'm not too
sure how we will go
i don't want to start discussing the
report but i think matters of
community representation need to
possibly take into account because
otherwise women's cue numbers
but does it matter if we skew numbers
people are represented
by a vote voting system and i would
certainly be
voted in agreement that that
includes a request a report be repaired
thank you councillor should we complete
the circle
councillor skelt give you anything you'd
like to add
councillor arnold um well i
sort of agree with councillor keith i
agree with councillor soper
so i'm sort of heavily thinking at this
stage
um i believe in democracy and i see
we've had good representation in recent
times
um but i understand
we were looking at going i guess with
all of this as well so
still in the thinking mode i'm gonna
have to make my mind up very shortly but
and whether it has any bearing which way
i vote
or not will depend if i'm number seven
you know
[Laughter]
thanks councillor actually we're only
making a decision about one thing as was
pointed out and
and the other is a report as the
penultimate speaker
um i'm quite comfortable with that
situation
i was enthusiastic about the last
representation review and some of
the suggestions it came forward with i'm
embarrassed that we have not enacted
them
and i see this as an opportunity to to
go
some way to more meaningfully
engaging during the election campaign
two years ago or 18 months ago somebody
asked me what i thought about
maori representation and it was obvious
the position that they held and my
response was
what are you afraid of they're the ogs
in sustainability
if i can use the modern vernacular
without sounding like a sad old
middle-aged man
but it's about understanding what what
the viewpoint is
um and as councillor lewis said you get
some interesting contributions there are
still a democratic process that we go
through afterwards
and this is still yet to be decided in
in a paper that we've yet to receive
counselor amundsen thanks chair
um i guess for me the difference between
having either manoa fenugreeks or
amari ward and just and having maori
elected to council
at large is just that if they are here
because they are appointed here or they
come through
a seat like that then they actually have
a mandate to speak for maori
and i think that's the difference we are
all elected at large our responsibility
is to speak
for this whole community and to think of
what's in the best interests of this
whole community the community of indica
and bluff
if we were an award system and i was
elected to represent south invercargill
then my mandate would be to speak for
south invercargill
so i think to me that's the the
difference and the reason
having people who have a mandate to
speak on behalf of maori is important is
because
of the obligations that we have through
the treaty
and i think it's pretty clear that this
council has neglect
neglected those obligations
for too long and this is a great way to
get onto the journey
of remedying that um just in comment i
guess to
councillor clarks a couple of the points
that he raised around the local
government review
i guess if if they had have expected
us to do nothing for the next couple of
years while the review was happening
they probably wouldn't have changed the
rules so that we could be making this
decision now
and the comments around our committee
structure
i think yep good point our committee
structure might change in the next
election
and perhaps that needs to be taken into
consideration with the report that
is being put together that we actually
need to think about
uh what manifest representation would
look like with our existing committee
structure
but also other committee structures like
the one we had previously or other
committee structures we might
have in the future and i guess just
finally
i would really like to extend my thanks
to the staff to michael in particular
and to the community panel who have
helped
you know gather the information um and
to rhiannon and her team for letting us
piggyback in
on some of the ltp consultations so that
we were able to
be part of that rather than creating
another whole set of
engagement with the community at the
same time i think that was
way less confusing and less onerous for
everybody so
really appreciate that thank you thank
you councillors
thank you for your engagement thank you
for your debate
we have two recommendations that have
been moved and seconded i'll put that
now all in favor
all right against would you like your
votes recorded yes please thank you
thank you emotionless carrick thank you
that brings us to the activity report
i'll move that that report be received
it's a seconder for that
also thank you steve what's the stuff
that's excited you
uh kia ora you cheer your worship
counselors um
but darren leaving's exciting
you've already touched on the
performance of the building team and the
consent performance there
the only other point i'd note in the
activity report through to the end of
march
is that the impact of covert and the um
the short change in alert levels early
march it still had an impact on
attendances both through the library
into the cab um into our building here
sorry and into the
i guess our other facilities and that is
having a lag
on participation rates and also that
will have an impact on our budgets
towards the end of the year it is it is
new territory for us really
um and interesting to see how that has
panned out essentially 12 months on from
the full lockdown uh interesting to note
though that as far as venues go much as
the big lady next door suffered quite a
hit
with the civic not being used for ages
that it's got a pretty busy heap of
activity going on in the victoria rooms
at the moment and securing a
long-term tenant over several months is
is also really pleasing to say
and the feedback from uh the dhb
staff working in there on the on the
support and service that they're getting
from our theater staff is really
positive
because there's any other comments or
questions that you have on the report
if not it's been moved and seconded i'll
put the motion all in favor
against carried that's all we have
in open we still have the public
excluded
um but it takes 10 minutes to swap
things over from one stream to another
for the extraordinary infrastructure
services meeting and just to get
everybody in there
so i'll adjourn when we reconvene for
ppp we will be
in public excluded at that stage so i'll
move that we go into
public excluded for the reasons as
outlined by the june
thank you put that all in favor against
carried we are adjourned in the meantime
and in 10 minutes
councillor pollinger it's yours
we solving satay yeah
you